PAUL SAXMAN: Hello.
My name is Paul Saxman.
I work at Developer Relations
in Google.
And I'm here to talk about
Google TV, specifically why
should developers build
apps for Google TV?
To answer this, here are a few
points to get you thinking.
TVs are by far the largest
displays in most households,
which means they're great
for consuming
content, especially video.
If you've ever watched YouTube
on a television, it's a great
experience.
TVs are connected to the best
sound systems in most
households, so audio apps work
great too on Google TV.
Pandora is one of the top
apps in Google TV.
TVs are near very comfortable
furniture in most households,
so developers should think about
the lean-back experience
or about what apps make sense
in the living room.
TVs are great for multi-user
viewing/interaction, so
developers should
think social.
TVs are used by over 5 billion
people worldwide.
On average, Americans watch
about five hours of TV daily,
which is increasing.
TV viewing is actually the top
leisure activity besides
sleeping in the United States.
In 2009, the average US home had
2.5 people versus 2.86 TV
sets, which means there are more
TVs than people in the
average US home.
And one more point to consider,
TVs aren't only
found in people's living rooms.
They're also commonly
found in bedrooms, hotel rooms,
classrooms, airplanes,
hospitals, lobbies, bars, and
quite a few other places.
Basically, TVs are everywhere.
A lot of people watch
them a lot.
And they're getting
smarter every day.
Would you like to learn more
about why to build
apps for Google TV?
Please check out these
resources.